let's take a look at the solution to
this it's a little bit tricky firstly at
the top of our file we declare two new
variables frame rate and frame now frame
rate represents how often we'd like to
actually call the animate function frame
is a variable that we're going to use to
represent what the current frame in our
flip book is since we already have our
frames array available the next step is
to actually loop through our predefined
assets and load each of the defined
images into the frames array this
follows the same three-step process we
saw before create a new image set its
onload result and then set its source
once this is done we can actually call
the set interval function which we'll
call the animate function at the frame
rate that we provided before now the
animate function has a little bit of
tricky logic inside of it first off we
have our frame counter that we've
defined we use this to define what image
out of the frames array we have to draw
to the canvas and of course at our
lovely position of 192 by 192 once we've
drawn the current frame we actually have
to increment it that's where this little
nice piece of math comes along what we
do is increment the frame counter and
then modulo it by the frames length what
will occur here is that if frame ever
becomes longer than frame length the
modulo function will have it loop around
back to 0 without us having to have all
the other if statements involved this is
a nice little piece of math that you
should put in your code your employer
will be impressed by it now if you
followed all the code you should see
something like this running around on
the screen if you'll notice something
this doesn't exactly look right you
actually get each of the frames drawn
over each other creating this sort of
halo effect there's a reason for this
it's worth noting that the canvas
doesn't actually clear itself each frame
instead it allows you to just keep
piling pixels on it as you go in order
to get rid of that ghosting effect you
have to put this line that we've
conveniently left out of our previous
function back in and that is context
clear rect what this will do is actually
clear all the pixels to some default
value allowing us to draw back on top of
it so you won't get the previous images
actually drawn on top of each other the
result is a nice nifty walk and robot
running around on your screen just like
it should the results with clear rect is
this nice fancy walk and robot